[Musique]
bonjour à tous est ravie de vous
retrouver dans cette nouvelle émission
de parlement hebdo l'essentiel de la
semaine politique et parlementaire dont
journée qu'un bonjour katia bonjour à
tous notre invité cette semaine sur soi
l'amour bonjour vous êtes député de
paris députés les républicains président
de la commission nationale des
investitures
évidemment on y reviendra très
longuement un peu plus tard dans cette
émission on commentera toute l'actualité
de la semaine notamment ce débat des
primaires de la gauche les sept
candidats en lice ont débattu une
dernière fois avant le vote de dimanche
et puis on parlera à l'assemblée
nationale du gaz de schiste qui étaient
au menu de députés et puis évidemment on
reviendra sur les questions
d'investiture qui ont posé quelques
couacs cette semaine et on commence tout
de suite avec le débat de la primaire à
gauche derniers temps forts de la
primaire
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'était donc ce jeudi la dernière ligne
droite pour les sept candidats benoît
hamon a été cette fois la cible des
critiques
son projet notamment de revenu universel
les candidates aussi beaucoup parlé d'un
grand absent à cette primaire pourtant
très présents emmanuel macron écouter on
a droit de regarder ce que dit emmanuel
macron je trouve pas ça inintéressant je
trouve tout cela simplement vieux je ne
comprends pas comment on peut aller au
puy du fou chez monsieur philippe de
villiers faire son éloge ensuite prendre
le train allait à nevers faire l'éloge
de françois mitterrand puis reprendre le
train allait à shannon h et valéry
giscard d'estaing faire l'éloge du
président giscard d'estaing il cherche à
faire croire que c'est pas la gauche qui
a nommé à pas de chance il était
ministre de hollande
et je pense aussi de manuel valls se
croit et puis à un moment il va sortir
de l'ambiguïté
ça peut être à son détriment mais sa
grande famille l'accueillera
c'est à vous savez l'enfant prodige il y
a les forces politiques force de presse
et fort qu'ils veulent empêcher que
cette primaire se passe dans de bonnes
conditions
emmanuel macron jean françois lamour
c'est le problème de la gauche c'est
aussi problème de la droite c'est un
problème pour tous c'est surtout un
problème pour la gauche en gros tout ce
petit monde est
comptable d'un quinquennat terrible
celui de françois hollande
ils ne savent pas comment s'en dépêtrer
on le voit bien d'ailleurs avec manuel
va c'est une bonne partie des candidats
à la primaire à gauche y compris
d'ailleurs mâcon macron j'ai
l'impression qu'il est le perdreau de
l'année je rappelle qu'il a été
conseillé de hollande sur des sujets non
neutre qui sont essentiellement liés à
l'école avec les sondages c'est visible
qu'il a été dans le jeu le répète
conseiller de françois hollande en
charge de l'économie on voit dans quel
état et l'économie française qui la
ferait moins bien entrailles sa famille
politique et qu'il est aujourd'hui dans
une logique un peu attrape tout est-ce
que vous avez au jeu est-ce que vous
avez aujourd'hui est-ce que vous avez
aujourd'hui une idée de son programme
économique
est-ce que vous avez vous l'avez déjà
entendu parler du régalien en
particulier en matière de sécurité de
défense et de relations internationales
celles qui vont en appel la gare
d'économiser ça vous rappelle quelqu'un
dont on attend simplement savoir
contrairement à ce qu'a fait françois
fillon c'est à dire qu'il a chiffré les
les économies d'ailleurs il a été
fortement attaquée sur ce sujet on
attend de savoir où emmanuel macron fera
ses économies et surtout comment il va
se positionner dans l'échiquier
international
aujourd'hui nous n'avons aucune
information alors vous avez raison ça
prospère pourquoi sa prospère parce que
c'est certainement là très l'attrait du
neuf est peut-être pour la gauche une
sorte de bouée de sauvetage en 10 ans en
disant regardez un peu ce qui se passe à
la primaire on voit bien que ça ne prend
pas j'avais aussi de l'armement terre et
j'ai regardé de votre camp qu'ils
rejoignent également de notre camp de
quelqu'un de droite en général j'ai du
mal à savoir de qui vous voulez parler à
certains renaud dutreil qui a été député
des répondants tiers du train il ya très
très longtemps qu'il a quitté la
politique
c'est un homme d'affaires renaud dutreil
il l'était avant de faire un peu
d'atlantique
il est très très vite reparti voulez
rire du déni qui vont vers lui
ah oui c'est effectivement dans cas
d'ailleurs des négociations avec udi
c'est effectivement une question qu'il
faut que nous fassions c'est à dire
c'est que je vous cache pas plus qu'une
manette c'est une interrogation de voir
toujours et encore c'était fait un peu
bulle médiatique qui prospèrent
d'ailleurs vous vouliez vous n'en parlez
immédiatement alors que nous commençons
l'émission nous demandons simplement une
chose sans mésestimer cette dynamique
c'est quel est le programme avec
précision comment va-t-il réformer le
pays
on a eu un exemple c'est la loi macron
aujourd'hui la loi macron c'est quoi ce
sont essentiellement des cas qui
circulent en france et dont on voit bien
d'ailleurs que en gros une société sur
deux est en train de péricliter
c'est ça macron et sa réforme pour
l'autre pays donc on attend d'en voir
beaucoup plus on entend aussi beaucoup
plus avant évidemment de pouvoir dire
oui il ya peut-être une inquiétude
aujourd'hui c'est un et laurent je le
reconnais bien manquer il remplit des
salles mais on avait douze ont lavé
remplit des salles immenses
on avait fait des meetings très
important on a vu d'autres
arrêtez de prendre les français pour des
imbéciles je crois que c'est le message
que nous devons à la fin de l'émission
et faire en sorte que ces français
choisissent librement
le président de la république et non pas
que son dard à jacou d'observation et à
coude analyses concernant on reviendra
où l'on parlera des investitures
c'est ce que vous avez dit à l'instant
sur les négociations avec paris et tours
de maquereaux d'emmanuel matheron parce
que c'est important mais on verra on a
beaucoup de choses encore à voir
l'actualité cette semaine une image a
été extrêmement commenter celle d'un
jeune homme qui a giflé manuel valls qui
était en déplacement dans une petite
ville des côtes d'armor allant battre
exactement l'agresseur a été condamné
quand vous avez vu cette image que vous
voyez cette image qu est ce que ça vous
inspire
c'est une malade c'est là c'est la
politique aujourd'hui c'est à dire il ya
plus de filets ya enfin le l'homme
politique est aujourd'hui on s'est
largement critiqué largement remise en
question y compris quand il vient d'être
élu c'est un vrai sujet donc il faut
redonner de la hauteur à la politique
avoir une femme ou un homme politique à
la tête de l'état
qui tiennent bon qui tiennent les rênes
qui nous évite ce genre de comportement
qui est inacceptable
il accepta mais aussi parfois
inévitables est ce que vous pensez que
c'est possible de protéger au maximum et
candidat à la primaire toujours il ya
toujours un risque
il ya bien toujours en lice pour
n'importe quel homme et femme politique
mais il ya un risque aussi pour
n'importe quel français ce qu'ils se
baladaient sur la promenade des anglais
à nice
ils ont été aussi on le voit bien
attaquer lâchement donc on le voit
aujourd'hui c'est une société que je
vais pas qualifié de violent mais où
malheureusement effectivement son il
veut en faire de comparaison ce genre de
gestes peuvent exister en guest dj qui
veut rencontrer ces jeunes hommes pour
comprendre
est-ce que hausse alors franchement a
envoyé sa ce moment c'est pas trop mon
ma tasse de thé ça va on n'en n'ont pas
vraiment rien à comprendre quand comme
ça sans aucune raison on va j'y ferai
d'ailleurs n'importe qui un homme ou une
femme politique ou n'importe quel
responsable
tout ça n'a pas beaucoup de sens s'il
veut avoir des explications c'est son
droit
franchement je trouve que la ccc la
limite en tout cas que moi je ne
dépasserai pas en 2012 nicolas sarkozy
avait été empêchée dans une ville à
bayonne de pouvoir ne serait-ce que
déambuler à les rencontrer les gens
aujourd'hui manuel valls ne peut plus
quasiment faire un meeting par un homme
en bretagne où il est empêché lorsque la
farine et les gifler fait le parallèle
entre les deux les deux personnalités
c'est aujourd'hui un rapport à la
politique on ne sait en politique où la
paire vous demandons à la politique en
général ou le choquant et français
attendent beaucoup des politiques sont
très déçus d'où l'enjeu majeur de cette
présidentielle alors l'actualité
parlementaire à présent jean françois
lamour le gaz de schiste était au menu à
l'assemblée
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
une proposition de loi était examiné en
commission pour adapter le code minier
français à l'environnement l'occasion
aussi de reparler de la question du gaz
de schiste valérie brochard nous fait
une explication de texte
l'exploration et l'exploitation des
huiles et gaz de schiste totalement
interdite c'est le sens de l'amendement
surprise adopté hier à l'initiative d'un
rapporteur socialiste dans le cadre de
la réforme du code minier
je crois que la population n'est pas
uniquement la population les
responsables politiques sont opposés à
l'exploitation et à l'exploration des
huiles et gaz de schiste
c'est une étape complémentaire mais qui
ne remet pas en cause les choix qui ont
été faits dans ce domaine là équipe
réserve jeu je le dis équipe réserve
l'exploitation donc le gaz de houille ou
du gaz de couche pour le moment une
seule méthode d'extraction est connue la
fracturation hydraulique interdite
depuis 2011
désormais toute alternative semble
condamner sur les autres dossiers clés
qu'il s'agisse des mines d'or en guyane
où des forages pétroliers offshore
la proposition de loi socialiste doit
introduire une dose d'environnement et
de démocratie dans un code minier vieux
de 60 ans principales mesures du texte
la création de groupements participatif
où les élus les acteurs économiques et
les associations seront associés avant
tout projet d'exploitation
mais les élus écologistes craignent que
les citoyens ne soient consultés que de
manière facultative
dernier point qui alimente les débats la
proposition de loi prévoit que l'état ne
puisse pas refuser un permis miniers
sauf s'ils apportent la preuve d'une
conséquences graves et irréversibles
pour l'environnement une définition trop
vague pour les écologistes et certaines
associations
bien que présenté en procédure accélérée
avec une seule lecture à l'assemblée et
au sénat la réforme a pourtant peu de
chances d'aboutir avant la fin de la
session parlementaire prévue fin février
quelle est votre position vous sur cette
question et deuxième question qui en
découle est ce que ces questions la
faune
en bonne place dans le programme de
françois fillon mais d'abord vous votre
position ma position c'est que notre
collègue chanteguet fait fausse route
non pas sur la fracturation hydraulique
à l'évidence cette ce procédé est
extrêmement néfaste pour l'environnement
et il dit de toute façon il est interdit
il faut évidemment continuer à la
dernière je pense que en revanche on ne
peut pas se priver de continuer à
chercher une bombe recéder
d'exploitation différent aujourd'hui il
n'existe pas il faut bien le reconnaître
mais comment peut-on imaginer que le
progrès technique en matière
d'exploitation de ce type de ressources
naturelles que d'autres pays exploite
d'ailleurs à travers sa faune baisser
leurs charges en matière de d'énergie
nous nous devons je crois de passer d'un
principe de précaution qui empêche tout
en précisant de responsabilité et
l'agent vient finalement à votre
question sur le programme de françois
fillon c'est ce qu'il souhaite faire
il est finalement le principe de
précaution nous empêche d'explorer de
nouveaux procédés de faire de l'arsenal
de très très haut niveau de la recherche
fondamentale de la recherche appliquée
en tas en particulier en matière
environnementale d'entreposage de
précaution je pense qu'il faut le
transformer faut pas le combo venez
faire un geste en disant balayé c'est
pas le sujet on balaie rien on dit il
faut transformer ce principe de
précaution en principe de responsabilité
à s'engager dans un type d'exploitation
par exemple du gaz de schiste et gaz de
schiste avec un procédé qui le permet
sans détruire l'environnement
c'est là la grande différence évidemment
qui nous sépare en particulier de la
gauche et en particulier des écologistes
je crois que c'est en termes de vision
de la société aussi un changement assez
radical je le reconnais un logiciel
différent qui est de dire on peut pas
s'empêcher aujourd'hui de croire au
progrès si nous empêchons nos chercheurs
si nous empêchons nos techniciens qu'on
a d'ailleurs de très très haut niveau
dans notre pays à faire des recherches
dans ce domaine alors nous serons
dépendants
nous serons dépendants d'autres pays qui
auront fait les efforts en matière
d'investissements en recherche et
développement
ça laisse à cette position pour conclure
c'est la position de notre collègue
christian jacob qui avait effectivement
relisant présent du groupe qui avait
effectivement interdit fait interdire
l'exploitation des gaz de schiste par
fracturation hydraulique mais qui ne
s'étaient pas empêché de trouver
effectivement un procédé innovant qui
n'existe pas encore mais dont on a
absolument besoin pour exploiter ces
trente secondes encore sur ce sujet il
ya un an luc chatel avait dit que les
républicains devaient être répartis gaz
de schiste et des ogm avait-il ajouté il
avait raison je vous incite à le
réécouter quand il est venu parler au
conseil national samedi il a eu un
traître d'ailleurs peu entendu ce
discours en faut bien mais on était
plutôt dans la cuisine à la beaucoup
d'oppositions souvenez vous en passer
l'ambiance était comme elle était celle
d'un conserver l'udc a effectivement
parlé beaucoup de recherches et et le
projet et il a eu effectivement un mot
sur les nouvelles technologies
un mot sur cette capacité à aller
vraiment de l'avant sur les ogm
également il faut je crois que nous
continuons à chercher dans ce domaine
mais en l'encadrant c'est la différence
entre le principe de précaution et le
principe de responsabilité vous que
souhaite imposer françois fillon dans
notre pays
au palais du conseil national on y vient
tout de suite
[Musique]
la conseil national on a beaucoup parlé
des investitures entre les sarkozystes
entre les juppéiste on va voir
exactement tout ce qui s'est passé avec
stéphanie des pierres et notamment ce
résumé un petit peu de cette semaine
politique du côté de la droite il
retrouve et que c'est lui le patron
en arrivant au conseil national françois
fillon a un objectif clair le vainqueur
de la primaire veut mettre un terme à la
contestation portée par certains
sarkozystes comme laurent wauquiez la
droite à laquelle je crois
elle parle des efforts et elle parle
aussi assez classe moyenne qui
travaillent et qui aujourd'hui à la fin
du monde pas l'impression que leurs
efforts sont reconnus notre devoir à
nous c'est de les entendre c'est de
proposer des mesures qui aillent vers
eux et tout simplement de défendre la
valeur travail
à la tribune le vice-président du parti
interpelle françois fillon l'unité ce
n'est pas l'uniformité
tu n'as pas besoin de clown autour de
toi tu n'as pas besoin de courtisans
la réponse ne s'est pas fait attendre la
mise au point de françois fillon est
ferme
non il ne reviendra pas sur la
défiscalisation des heures
supplémentaires non il n'a douce ira pas
son programme
je ne vais pas changer ce que je crois
est ce que je veux en fonction des
vapeurs des uns et des injonctions du
microcosme
il m'arrive d'entendre certains à droite
utilisé les mêmes mots que la gauche que
ma victoire et pu décevoir certains jeux
puis le concevoir mais j'attends de mon
parti de la responsabilité et de la
discipline
la majorité des ténors du parti appelle
à faire bloc derrière françois fillon
mais certains s'inquiètent déjà de la
présence de voix discordantes
si vous voulez gagner
y a pas de place pour la division
l'unité c'est la clé de la victoire les
petites voix personnelle
les critiques pour se valoriser soi même
de valoriser sa famille politique tout
ça ça ne mène nulle part sur le non
cumul des mandats là aussi françois
fillon reste inflexible
il l'a redit devant ce parterre d'élus
pas question de faire marche arrière
même s'ils ont officiellement été
investi samedi les cumulards devront
donc choisir entre députés ou mandat
local d'ici les législatives de juin
un v6 on va parler d investiture dans un
instant simplement sur ce qu'a dit
françois fillon il ne va pas changer
michèle alliot marie dit ce vendredi
matin qu'il stresse et français
n'ont-ils l'heure où je pense qu'il leur
trace une route pleine d'espoir c'est
l'enfant de réformer notre pays avec un
un projet cohérent puissant certes
réformateur évidemment où effectivement
on va falloir faire des efforts c'est
évident mais d'ailleurs ils sont les
yeux c'est la vérité qui me tient
vraiment aux tripes qui veut expliquer
aux français que ce projet là il ya pour
redresser la france pour en faire un
pays où on entre bien dans la rue mais
donc cette semaine les parlementaires
c'est à vous êtes rencontrés à une
semaine je vous dis pas d'espoir il ne
porte pas ses joueurs ainsi si je suis
en train justement de vous dire qu'elle
est l'espoir qu'elle est la vision les
députés disent ils françois fillon
répète qu'il veut faire en dix ans la
france
être le premier pays d'europe vous serez
pas que c'est un espoir ça aurait pas
que c'est une ligne directrice ou vous
raconter deux directement et
parlementaires ne pourrait pas que c'est
un objectif ambitieux pour notre pays
pour autant il faut le réformer
c'est ce que c'est ce contrat que
françois fillon avec ce principe de
vérité qu'il propose aux français
également ça bouscule parce que y
compris chez infernal de nos
parlementaires
on peut penser qu'on peut réformer le
pays sans effort et sans se remettre en
question soi même c'est pas possible
d'ailleurs je pense que peut-être ces
vingt dernières années on a essayé on a
bien vu que ça n'avait pas fonctionné
donc ça c'est ce projet cohérent et
puissant que françois fillon propose
directement aux français
maintenant les parlementaires et on l'a
vu au conseil national
on peut évidemment comprendre qu' ils
soient en train de réacquérir après
cette primaire qui a été grande qualité
qui a été aussi pour leurs candidats
plein d'espoir maintenant je pense que
voilà des choses vont
arrivés en ordre de marche et on va
pouvoir travailler vraiment je suis
tellement cette enquête qui a été menée
par le monde pour avec le cevipof
notamment qu'une enquête sérieuse au
près de 15000 personnes et là on voit
que françois fillon perd des points 3 4
points dans les sondages dans ce sondage
10 points chez les électeurs centristes
7 points chez les républicains il ya un
trou d'air non il n'ya pas un trou d'air
il ya par définition après la surprise
que vous avez vécu d'ailleurs comme tout
le monde
en tout cas beaucoup de beaucoup de
personnes de françois fillon en tête au
premier tour à 44 % puis vainqueur de
cette primaire sans aucune contestation
et a par définition quand on est la
cible de beaucoup de critiques
une sorte de mécaniquement une sorte de
baisse dans les sondages mais vous
l'avez compris c'est pas obligatoirement
les sondages qui font bouger françois
fillon il l'a toujours dit lui il va
parler aux français
le discours du conseil national de
samedi dernier était important celui qui
va compter celui qui est en quelque
sorte le début de la campagne
présidentielle c'est celui du 29 janvier
qu'il fera à la villette
alors il ya une autre question qui est
assez central pour tous les partis celle
de la parité sur combien de femmes
visées vous pour les législatives est ce
que vous êtes prêts à payer des amendes
alors si vous ne respectez pas l'âge et
surtout vous dire d'où on part
aujourd'hui il ya 25% de femmes à
l'assemblée c'est évidemment peu et est
pas acceptable aujourd'hui on est aux
alentours de 38 % et nous négocions vous
le savez un accord avec lui dit mais
nous avons aussi une ressource
supplémentaire si je peux me permettre
d'employer ce terme là c'est qu'un
certain nombre de nos collègues qui sont
touchés par le cumul des mandats vont
choisir
j'en connais ils sont de plus en plus
nombreux à choisir leur collectivité
plutôt de l'assemblée il préfère avoir
cette capacité à agir directement
circuits courts sur leur territoire donc
ça va nous donner aussi là le moyen de
discuter avec eux s'ils ont un choix à
faire entre deux personnalités de
qualité un homme et une femme vous tenez
bien conduire on leur propose
effectivement de choisir une femme mais
j'ai bien dit à qualité égale on n'est
pas largué pour eux c'est toujours ses
problèmes de quotas donne le son dépasse
les compétences et des qualités
si le compte n'y est pas opposée
d'humiliation je vais vous dire très
clairement au jour
on n'attendra pas la parité parfaite 50%
en deux sets
on paiera d une avance mais encore une
fois regardez d'où on part les parties
de 25%
on est aux alentours de 40% je pense qu
on rattrapera présumant notre retard on
avait beaucoup de sortants de 2 c à
l'issue de ce mandat législatif en tout
cas l'effort est sensible il nous faut
poursuivre et c'est mon rôle en tant que
président de la ceni que de le faire
jusqu'au dernier moment
message reçu on va accueillir à présent
notre partenaire du figaro.fr
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bon aujourd'hui bonjour michael jour
jean françois lamour
il ya donc des doutes sur le projet on
on l'est on les a entendus il ya
quelques secondes il ya aussi des
désaccords sur les investitures et
notamment sur celles vous avez
évidemment vu cette semaine de nathalie
kosciusko morizet dans le fief de
françois fillon à paris on a entendu
rachida dati parlé de scandale de fait
du prince
bon c'est une réaction plutôt su attendu
de la part de rachida dati on connaît
les relations conflictuelles entre les
deux femmes ce qu'il est peut-être moins
c'est la méthode avec laquelle
d'investiture dan qui m a été décidée
puis il n'y a pas eu de vote
pourquoi avoir à viviez en catimini sur
sac et ça met ya jamais de vote la cia
c'est un peu surprenant vous me posez la
question puisque vous semblez bien
informée je suis président de la ceni
depuis maintenant plus d'un mois et demi
nous avons eu à passer une centaine à
peu près de deux candidatures
à aucun moment il n'y a eu un vote donc
je suis assez surpris vous me posiez la
question
ça fait en général attire mais n'est pas
membre de la ceni elle ne l'a jamais été
d'ailleurs mais donc il ya jamais eu
droit d en général d'ailleurs ça se fait
plutôt par consensus un indice est en
ordre de françois fillon
c'est un ordre vous savez il ya une
sorte qu'on appelle une sorte de droit
de suite que nous avons puis vient
quasiment respectée dans tous les cas
c'est à dire que quand le candidat
sortant ne se représente pas il nous
propose une solution donc france office
a appelé il dans la dijonnaise n'a pas
appelé que moi dans la quasi totalité
des cas ces conseils ces propositions
ont été suivies il ya un ou deux cas au
sol n'a pas été mais vraiment c'est
vraiment à la marche posez la question à
l'ensemble de nos collègues sortant ils
vous diront qu effectivement ils nous
ont fait une proposition
dans le cas de la ceni est que cette
proposition est acceptée sans vote
et c'est assez surprenant que vous nous
parliez de vote puisque à aucun moment
il n'y a eu une une investiture validée
par un vote de la ceni j'espère j'espère
que ça va continuer jusqu'à la fin et
jusqu'à ce que nous ayons investi tout
ou partie des 577 députés qui pourraient
ne représenter lors de la
prochaine mandature alors justement il
ya d'autres cas un peu problématique qui
peuvent se poser notamment par exemple
celui d'henri guaino dont la cantonale a
ainsi regretté je les sais c'est quoi le
oui en gros pourquoi ici retire sa
candidature il aura ça si ça sert qu on
a le sentiment surtout quand rigueur
mais pas simplement lu notre collègue
gorge aussi le début des méchas et
candidat alain dirigeants ciel ses deux
collègues le sentiment qu'il donne c'est
qu'il s'éloigne de notre famille
politique
quand on n'accepte pas le principe de la
primaire et son résultat est qu'on
recherche les parrainages à la
présidence de la république ou ce que
vous appelez que vous appelez ça comment
ils se mettent en réserve de notre parti
donc s'ils se mettent en réserve d'une
partie parce qu'ils n'acceptent pas des
principes de la primaire est normal que
nous réservions leur circonscription
c'est rentrer dans le droit on a
l'impression qu'on est à la caserne on
est quand même dans une campagne
présidentielle soit emmener avec soi on
est contre mais non c'est soit né dans
une famille soit on n'y est pas vous en
conviendrez aux jeunes en dehors de la
famille ben aujourd'hui il est en marge
il est pas en dehors il est en marge on
attend de savoir ce qu'il veut faire
est ce qui la sépare n a jusqu il
présentait la garde et michèle
alliot-marie nes et nos réserves du
parti parce qu'elle est candidate à la
présidentielle
bon ben voilà c'est simple c'est clair
pas de sanction pour elle
important succès voilà il ya aucune
sanction c'est pas une sanction c'est
simplement pour le compte
un principe de précaution voilà on ne
sait pas exactement ce que veut faire on
rit guaino on attend de savoir si oui ou
non il part à la présidentielle
eh bien on en tirera les conséquences
quand il l'aura décidé est ce que le cas
de la succession de patrick balkany à
levallois était réglé nos oreilles et
toujours henry est toujours en cours
nous choisirons le meilleur candidat
pour cette pour cette circonscription
ça peut être un patrick balkany non non
ça sera pas patrick bailly d'ailleurs il
n'est pas candidat comme vous le savez
mais donc nous choisirons vraiment le
meilleur candidat celui qui est en
capacité de gagner qui nous apportera
c'est un peu le principe d'ailleurs et
la demande de françois fillon l'a mon
égard c'est de nous choisir une une
majorité solide
voilà parce que on aura effectivement
besoin contrairement à ce qui se passe
aujourd'hui avec françois hollande d'une
majorité qui tiennent le cap et qui se
laisse pas entraîner comme on l'a vu
avec les frondeurs dans des positions
que je qualifie d' exotiques et qui a
quasiment tué la mandature de françois
hollande maj majorité solide avec les
centristes c'est votre gros dossiers du
moment vous allez négocier avec eux des
désaccords de circonscription ils en
veulent une centaine quasiment de
réussir conscription gagnaire vous leur
proposez la moitié ce qui sont trop
gourmands selon vous là aussi on peut
plutôt que parler de marchandage et du
nom de deux sièges
je regarde simplement ce qu'il faut pour
françois fillon ce qu'il lui faut c'est
cette majorité solide la plus large
possible au sein des républicains avec
un soutien évident d'allier dont on nous
dit qu'ils sont également solides
c'est la famille centriste mais une
famille qu'est vous savez qu'on pose
est-ce verse plusieurs sous famille 1
pour faire clair celle de la garde celle
de maurin celle de hainard est celle de
folio ça fait quatre familles qui se
réunissent au sein de deux ans 10 succès
dont conviendrait pas simple quand on
négocie avec eux donc un allié solide et
là où je crois il ya encore une
différence d'appréciation
c'est dans la menace du front national
et des triangulaires nous nous estimons
que parce que les français on en parlait
tout à l'heure sont exaspérés des cinq
ans de hollande
les français sont vraiment tenté par des
extraits mais on risque d'avoir un grand
nombre de triangulaires et il nous faut
maintenir quand même une solidité de la
majorité pour françois fillion doullens
au travers d'où l'intérêt d'avoir des
candidatures uniques d'avoir des
candidatures uniques mais vous en
conviendrez aussi d'avoir une famille
les républicains large et celui de mai
autour tout à l'heure vous parlez vous
pas renié donc voilà pour manuel macron
par rapport à un but et eagle mot
casserait les sanctions possibles que je
vois aujourd'hui 1 contrairement à ce
qui se passe aux républicains ce que je
vois aujourd'hui c'est que on a quelques
exemples de députés sortants par exemple
qui sont allés assister à des meetings
de macron juni c'est aussi un article
dans un journal des ardennes où un
candidat investi par l'idée y annonce
qu'il va être qu'il va continuer à être
investis par ludique mais qu'il appelle
à voter mâcon donc c'est aussi un
problème pour la droite c'est surtout un
problème pour lutter ils vont donc de
plus que pour les rues qu'est ce qui se
passe c'est bien ça ça fait partie des
sujets que je vais évoquer dès la
semaine prochaine avec mes homologues en
particulier mais qu'il choisit collègues
c'est eux qui vont dire comment
effectivement ils vont traiter ce genre
de cas parce que s'il y en a un je pense
qu'il y en aura d'autres qui viendront
parler rapidement sur le modem est ce
qu'il va voir un accord avec le modem
et si oui qui pourraient être investis
on parle notamment de marielle de sarnez
qui prouve est confirmée lorgner sur une
star ici on parle non non je ne peux pas
vous non puisque nous avons investi jean
pierre lecoq maire dû 6e
donc ça non je ne pense pas que ce soit
et pour tout vous dire moi je n'ai
aujourd'hui aucun mandat pour parler
avec le modèle aucun regret venant
période de fêtes si j'ai bien compris
françois bayroux hésitent beaucoup à
partir donc là déjà il faut que lui-même
se mettront paix avec ce pays où
l'information qui apparaît aujourd'hui
man 2 ça ne sera pas candidate
ou alors je n'avais pas eu cette
information non je dis on a investi jean
pierre lecoq sur la 11e circonstances je
pense que c'est celle là que vous faites
référence aux affaires merci beaucoup
merci notre invité et on se retrouve
très bonne semaine à tous
[Musique]